merci monsieur le président bienvenue à
tous il me revient la responsabilité de
vous présenter donc les comptes de
l'exercice 2015
vous avez en avoir la primeur je
souffrais un très bref rappel en ce qui
concerne le budget 2016 que vous avez
voté lors du dernier conseil national
l'anssi concerne les comptes de
l'exercice 2015
il ya plusieurs bonnes nouvelles vous
avez tout d'abord un niveau de recettes
proche des objectifs très ambitieux qui
étaient fixés dans le budget des
recettes qui sont en hausse de 13% par
rapport à 2014 et puis par ailleurs en
ce qui concerne les dépenses nous avions
lancé une politique d'économies qui
s'est poursuivie après 2014 puisque nous
avons une baisse des dépenses de 11 %
par rapport à 2014
par ailleurs nous avons pour la première
année en 2015 commencer à rembourser
notre dette 5,8 millions d'euros et puis
vous le savez les 2015 a été l'année de
la relance du mouvement qui est devenu
des républicains alors les résultats du
parti pour 2015 s'élève à 8,4 millions
d'euros auxquels il faut ajouter cher
thierry solère le préfinancement de la
primaire qui n'étaient pas initialement
prévue au budget pour huit cent mille
euros ce qui fait que témoin bien que
l'excédent 2015 est de 9,2
millions d'euros contre 3 millions 9
euros en 2014
il ya donc une augmentation de
l'excédent de 136% 2015 c'est votre
travail
bravo et merci alors comment est on
arrivé à ce résultat très rapidement ce
qui concerne les recettes et sont en
progression de 13% par rapport à 2014
grâce à deux points de postes sur
lesquels je veux revenir un instant les
dons nationaux puisque notre objectif de
collecte de dons a été atteint et il est
surtout en forte progression par rapport
à 2014 et je veux remercier le président
sarkozy puisque dès son élection en
décembre 2014 on a vu les dons affluent
et au mouvement et ça s'est poursuivi
tout au long de l'année 2015 avec une
augmentation des doses des dons de 73%
des objectifs de dons qui sont donc
quasiment atteint au regard du budget
prévisionnel et des coûts de collecte
qui ont même été diminuée puisque quand
on regarde les dons il faut regarder les
recettes mais également les coûts de
collecte ainsi qu'en ces années
cotisations des élus
je sais que c'est un point auquel les
militants sont attentifs à juste titre
sachez que ces cotisations des élus sont
en progression significative par rapport
au budget prévisionnel en à un million
d'euros de plus de cotisations d'élus
par rapport à ce qui était prévu au
budget et surtout par rapport à 2014
on a une hausse de 1,3 millions d'euros
80 2 % c'est-à-dire que nous avons
quasiment doublé par rapport à l'année
dernière la recette des cotisations des
élus
les élus des républicains payent leur
cotisation poules mouillées
nous l'avons fait ou presque puisqu'il
ya encore quelques rares élus qui se
font tirer l'oreille mais je suis
certain qu'ils vont s'empresser de
régulariser leur situation
du côté des dépenses nous avons des
dépenses donc ils sont maîtrisées des
dépenses de personnel qui sont en net
retrait voyez les effectifs 101 en 2013
87 en 2014
2015 des frais financiers qui commencent
à baisser c'est un effet heureux du
remboursement de la dette
le respect du budget pour l'immobilier 1
réalisé pour les directions retrait de
15% par rapport à 2014 et donc
globalement les dépenses de structure
sont en retrait de 1,9 million d'euros
soit 11 % par rapport à l'exercice
précédent notre politique d'économie que
je vous avais annoncé il ya un peu plus
d'un an a donc été tenu en ce qui
concerne les engagements bancaires
donc comme je voulais dit nous avons
remboursé pour la première fois en
capital 5.5 millions d'euros en mars
2015 aux banques
nous avons commencé aussi à rembourser
ce que nous devons je salue mes
collègues parlementaires et députés de
l'assemblée nationale ont commencé à
rembourser le prêt du groupe l'est
républicain de l'assemblée nationale et
puis nous avons aussi renégocié en 2015
avec les banques un échéancier
supportable qui va nous permettre de
financer la primaire est aussi de
soutenir notre candidat pour l'élection
présidentielle au 31 10 en 2015 et
encore du travail du chemin à parcourir
mais oublie que la confiance est
rétablie notamment avec avec les banques
on a un endettement global qui est tombé
à 68 7 millions d'euros au lieu de 75 5
millions d'euros au 31 décembre 2014
le budget 2015 a permis de financer la
relance du mouvement devenu les
républicains je vais pas détailler ce
qui est indiqué ici sachez simplement
qu'on a pu faire de conseils nationaux
au lieu d'un et qu'on a pu notamment
également organiser le congrès fondateur
des républicains qui a été entièrement
financée par des économies on est resté
dans l' enveloppe du bij et 2015 pour
financer un deuxième conseil national et
le congrès fondateur des républicains et
on a même pu en fin d'année dégagé une
enveloppe de fric préfinancement pour la
primaire en ce qui concerne le budget
2016 que nous devons avoir tous en tête
il se caractérise par la poursuite de la
maîtrise des dépenses
des recettes qui doivent continuer à
être stimulé des relations avec les
fédérations qui sont simplifiées afin de
bien évidemment de rembourser et de
continuer à rembourser notre dette de
financer les primaires et l'action
pré-présidentielle nous avons signé deux
conventions de financement des primaires
nous avons pu dégager lepron dégagé 5
millions d'euros pour financer la
primaire en 2016
c'était un de nos objectifs il est
atteint en ce qui concerne les relations
avec les fédérations il ya des
présidents fération les secrétaires
départementaux dans la salle des
trésoriers départementaux je les
rencontrerai dans la journée également
des délégués de circonscription vous
êtes tous concernés en tant que
conseillers nationaux reculer cette
règle qui a été simplifié pour 2016
dès lors que vous faites une cotisation
adhésion ou des leur cas n'est dupe et
sa cotisation
un tiers seulement reste au conseil
national et les deux tiers vous
reviennent dans les départements nous
appliquons la même règle balade
j'espère que ça vous motivera pour
multiplier les adhésions et faire payer
les élus qui ne paieraient pas encore
leurs cotisations ils sont de plus en
plus rares on applique cette règle aux
français de l'étranger
et puis par ailleurs je suis réussite
vous annoncer que nous avons triplé la
dotation pour les jeunes républicains en
conclusion
que je salue j'aurais remercié le
président sarkozy parce que sans son
soutien sans sa confiance et sans sa
présence à la tête du mouvement
n'aurions pas pu redresser la situation
financière comme nous l'avons fait je
veux remercier aussi les membres du
comité financier qui m'accompagne
françois noël buffet caroline cayeux
dino cinieri maïlys courtois james
courty johanna de souza jean françois
lamour arad est la ville jacques lebigre
isabelle quéval laurent seillier et
tokia saïfi il ya cinq parlementaires et
cinq militants qui ont été tirés au sort
je leur bien évidemment remercié aussi
le bureau politique
les trésoriers départementaux remercié
frédéric péchenard et la direction des
ressources et l'ensemble des permanents
du mouvement et puis surtout vous
remercier vous tous qui est à nos côtés
ce mouvement c'est le vôtre
nous allons continuer à le redresser y
compris financièrement tous ensemble
merci pour votre soutien
bon congrès national merci